foreign
between
we United the leading economies of the
world to impose unprecedented costs
that are squeezing Russia's economic
lifelines
together
we've committed nearly 700 tanks
and thousands of armored vehicles
one thousand artillery systems
more than two million rounds of
artillery ammunition
more than 50 Advanced launch rocket
systems anti-ship and air defense
systems
all defend you to defend Ukraine and
that doesn't count
the other half a billion dollars were
going to be we're announcing with you
today and tomorrow
that's going to be coming your way
and that's just the United States in
this piece
and just today
that announcement includes artillery
ammunition for high Mars and howitzers
more javelins anti-armor systems air
surveillance Radars they'll protect
Ukrainian people from Aero bombardments
later this week we will announce
additional sanctions
against Elites and companies that are
trying to evade sanctions and backfill
Russia's War Machine
and thanks to bipartisan support in
Congress
this week we are delivering billions in
direct budgetary support
billions in direct budgetary support
which the government can put to use
immediately
and help provide for basic Services of
citizens
the cost that Ukraine has had to bear
has been extraordinarily High
and the sacrifices
have been far too great they've been met
with them in far too great
we mourn alongside the families of those
who've been lost to the brutal and
unjust War
we know that they'll be very difficult
days and weeks and years ahead
but Russia's aim was to wipe Ukraine off
the map
Putin's war of Conquest is failing
Russia's military has lost half its
territory once occupied
young talented Russians are fleeing are
the tens of thousands not wanting to
come back to Russia
not not just fleeing from the military
fleeing from Russia itself
because they see no future in their
country
and that's how long we're going to be
with you Mr President for as long as it
takes
we'll do it
[Applause]